Contrary to some of the other algorithms random
forest is actually fairly easy to understand.
Random forest just merges a collection of
independent decision trees to get a more accurate
and stable prediction.
Random forest is a type of ensemble method.
Ensemble combines several machine learning models
to decrease both bias and variance. The overall
idea here is that multiple models are fit and
each key in the different aspect of the data.
By combining these models, ultimately generate
better prediction together than any of those
single models on their own.
Let's look at a quick example. We will
start with what the training looks like,
and then we will look at what
it is like to test the model.
In training, this algorithm will take N samples
from the training data. This is sampling with
replacement. That means one single sample is
likely to appear in multiple different samples.
Then, the next step is to take a sample of
features to be used for each of the data samples.
In the Titanic dataset, if we have 7
features, each of these data samples,
maybe we'll sample four or five
of those features to be used.
So now, we have N subsets of our overall data.
And those subsets contain both a subset of
the rows and also a subset of the columns.
Then with the features and the data subset,
the algorithm will build a decision tree
and try to generate the most accurate
results. It's important to realize that these
decision trees are all developed on their own.
They do not know what the other trees are doing.
In summary, we would have N trees that are all
build independently on different subsets of data.
It's important that these trees are all
independent because you want each decision tree
to key in on different relationships in the data.
This will ultimately generate the best prediction.
Next, let's look at how the
prediction is generated.
Each of these tress represent a fit and concrete
model. We would take an example from the test set,
let’s call it example A. Example A will enter
into all trees that have been built and traverse
down the tree based on its features. Then,
each of the entry will generate a prediction.
Let’s look at the most left hand side tree. May
be example A stays at the cabin. Then move on to
the second layer of the tree, may be this person
pay the $50. Then, we move on to the third layer,
and may be this person is a female. Based on these
features, this model will predict that this person
would survive.
Now, the splits in the features on the
second tree will be totally different.
So, it's possible to get a different prediction.
If we continue the testing, you will have
N predictions for example A, one from each
tree. Then the random forest algorithm will
basically just aggregate all those predictions
together, and based on voting with majority rule,
you will make a final prediction. In this case,
it would predict that the person survived.
When should you consider using Random Forest?
Contrary to logistic regression in SVM, random
forest works quite well for problems with both
categorical and continuous target variables. One
of the major advantage of random forest is that it
has an attribute that lays out the importance
of each predictor that you're working with.
This is really helpful to understand the
relationships and the power of the features
that you're using in your model. Hence, random
forest is great as a quick benchmark model.
It tends to perform quite well, it's relatively
fast to train, and it's really quite flexible in
the type of data that it plays well with. On that
note, when you have really messy data with missing
values, outliers, and maybe skewed data, random
forest deals really well with that kind of data.
When should we not use this? While random forest
is fairly fast, flexible, and performs quite well,
it's not necessarily likely to be
the best model for any given problem.
If you want a quick model that gets you 90% of the
way there, it might be the right tool for the job,
but if you really need to get 100% of the way
there and extract all possible value out of the
data, random forest might not be the right tool.
While it's nice to understand the features,
and the decision trees on their own,
can be fairly easy to understand. When you have
a random forest of hundreds of decision trees,
it can be hard to interpret what's really
happening across that entire model. So, if you
need to see the details within the model, random
forest might not be the right choice for you.
In summary,
random forest is relatively quick to train, but
it's not quite as quick to make predictions.
Overall, random forest is a tremendously
flexible, relatively fast tool that
plays well with different data and can
give you relatively good performance.